hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to destiny rebellion
okay we just made our way out of the
haunted house so now we need to continue
on finding these uranium rods so that we
can blow something up or something like
that
hello are you important No okay is this
giant house important I would assume so
do I have a key for it this is the
mayor's residence I have no interest of
going in there
yes I do I have many interests of going
in there because there might be
something that I need okay what about
here the Medical Center was there
something shut up
who is that whistling howling doing that
oh no you don't
okay oh okay instantaneously inside not
even a loading screen not even a lantern
needed dear patients since plague a
pandemic recently occurs in the village
Medical Association urges you to hands
personal hygiene clinical tuberculosis
vaccine arrives we recommend seeing a
doctor in vaccines Plake infections
avoid contact quarantine is recommended
so what you're telling me is that
there's some infected individuals local
doctors asleep everyone's dead what are
you talking about asleep everyone died
I'm like the only no I'm like the only
one left in here why do you gotta be I
gotta be I gotta be such a douche look
oh I thought that was something what
about this one oh here we go
nuclear rod that was
[Music]
that was awfully convenient and that was
perfectly time for my lantern to go out
hello
what's with the banging booms why we boo
boom banging I don't have any oil left
what did I do
how did I waste all my oil hello I can't
touch you okay I guess I'm out of here
now I only need one more rod and then
I'll be good to go although I probably
the store has two complex mechanisms I
don't have any interest in going inside
it hi are you walking around naked at
night oh you're just adorable
what was that I'm gonna get you I'm
gonna get you you're naked guy hello
I know oh wait what oh I can't follow
the naked guy well why not well what the
hell
this is stupid was that another plague
victim yeah funk okay so I'm out of oil
so now I need to just continue forward
put your shop optional hell yeah I want
to go in the butcher shop absolutely yes
hello ding ding I would like some pig
meat please lots of it in a big ham hock
that I can shove down my throat it would
be nice to have some oil maybe I could
substitute the meat from the fat pig
stuff and put it in my lantern I don't
know what I'm talking about that is that
is a rather sinister look so what am I
looking for here is there anything in
here that I need oh thank you so much I
needed that really badly but that is not
a lot of oil you're giving me here so I
need to be very sparing about this okay
look look look look look there's a saw
as a piggy ah I didn't see this before
but I can't open it so there's no point
there's no point to any of this this is
all pointless was there a button that I
need to press I'm running out of oil
burning oil up need to move move move
move move nothing nothing nothing okay
there's nothing here there was no point
in coming in here okay crash who did
that who threw that funk the housekeeper
is probably asleep or dead you know
that's an option too he could be very
very very dead
yep yep come on there we go give me
while I break everything that you love
and cherish priceless artifacts oh hello
here we go nuclear rod number 6 what is
there a painting of the same painting
inside the painting no idea okay I'm out
of here thanks for the rod okay
Oh Nikes okay so here's the recap
I got oil from there and I went up on
that and now I'm able to get the now I'm
able to get this which is a fuel rod on
the backyard roof tops okay so I'm
officially missing one rod but I think
it's a backtrack into the one of the
buildings that I've already been so in
the interest of time I'm just gonna move
forward and because this is a very long
custom story I don't want to be hanging
around too much I don't think there's
anything new that I'm missing because I
don't get the six rod or not maybe not
maybe maybe I don't know but I think you
only need the four so that you can go in
here and do it I don't even know if
there's an option to put in six
okay so haha oh I see the time machine
target time and destination is set
correctly slightest mistake could cause
death of the time traveler at least four
rods are needed to make sure that
everything is going to work perfect
there's no need to connect more than
four rods because of sufficient reserves
okey dokey okay
[Music]
oh it took the rot away from me so there
really is no need for it so let's do
this
choo choo into the past or future I
think I'm going into the past to save my
wife my wife need to save her this is
really cool hot damn look at all those
special effects oh now I walk into the
past
chapter one yay there's like four
chapters in total or something like that
so yes we did it we did it on the back
I'm going into the future
okay oh my god I'm a monster aren't I
what's that
the claw monster
oh my god that's so cool it's so good in
the future we all have dial-up modems
fatal error how fatal are we talking
here oh no give me give me oh I'm so
cool ah I know it's not really any
different like that one monster sequence
from that one we need your custom story
but still but still it's pretty cool
okay go come on let's go let's go my god
piss balls our ass come on
need to take you with me yeah let's go
whoa okay there so the monsters are now
the center of the world how are they
reproducing dare I ask I didn't know all
the monsters sounded like Santa Claus
okay I get it I got it so there's a lot
of security going on in the monster
world oh that's not good let's see here
I've been in the bathroom I'm not even
gonna carry that Dwight I don't have a
lantern anymore but God that would be
annoying if I do whoa hi sorry I didn't
mean to walk in on your business I'll
just leave you alone is this piece of a
puzzle
I need the puzzle pace this dude didn't
do need this bro
get in here here take it I'll be on my
way you have a good day you have a good
day now doing whatever the hell it is
you're doing no see this work for you
yeah okay worked piss god dammit okay hi
hi there
God you look good look real good glad
I'm glad you look so good access denied
permanently that seems a little harsh
don't you think
yep open
give me my light give me my light okay
let's go all right now we need to get
out the level 2 door and go to wherever
the hell we're supposed to go to open it
up darlin Bluebird what with them don't
we read with them okay whatever you say
bro this light does not help much at all
oh I'm gonna lose it it is before ball
when a human babes like a monster but it
is prize worthy when a monster behaves
like a human okay I can't see anything
oh I'm here okay damn it I lost my light
and it's war oh my god what a monsters
the sky god damn it no one saw that
careful even monsters are not immortal
yeah yeah yeah whatever you didn't tell
me that the floor was entirely poison
and lava didn't know I was playing a
kids game here yeah
you stopped that you stepped up right
now yourself that right now shut up I
know what I'm doing come on come on come
on come on oh maybe I shouldn't have
gone that way
hello it's dangerous here it's dangerous
to go alone take this Oh
I didn't mean to I'm sorry I really am
I didn't think that actually kill you
what the hell oh my god ah my bad bro
whoa aim safe good after the horrible
murder that I did to my comrades it's
probably for the best
you know what I'm gonna take that axe
with me yeah you shut up whatever that
growling noise was I didn't even see
that savegame dig this with me cuz this
seems like an effective weapon here no
no no
there we go now we got it now we're in
it to win it
nice ass bro yeah yeah okay we made it
all the way to the other side and I
didn't have any other trouble none at
all
hello smash whoa this thing is way more
powerful than I thought it was I guess
I'm just used to uh okay what was all
that alarm triggers or deadly deadly
bombs
how am I supposed to go under there it's
exactly I level it's gonna cut the top
of my head off okay okay
okay time for some sick ninja trick
moves like this okay
this is easy OOP oh hi oh sorry
oh my god I really am should I go in
there am I supposed to go in here can I
go in here I guess I'm not why would you
be uh why would I have an idea to go in
there after I just saw pieces of my
friends being chewed up and spit out
what am I supposed to do oh yeah ah hey
baby ah where the axe doesn't work the
claw will definitely be an ample
substitute okay how about you get the
right orientation thank you
is it someone there is that a person is
that the outline of a person what is
that what is that what is that oh oh
it's a chair sorry never mind everybody
you shut up you back the F up
gonna next for your ass I will axe you
so hard bro okay what was the point of
getting aqua vitae that doesn't help me
I don't have any light I can't see a
damn thing
hello oh this I was supposed to take
this in there okay okay so can I see
anything else oh hi hi there my friend
how you doing good you doing good good
here anything buried in there no yeah I
don't see anything else okay I really
didn't see anything else in there I
don't know why I needed to go in there
maybe I'm assuming that I needed to get
this light so that I could actually move
forward and see where I was going out
here yeah that looks like it's coming
right across my eyeballs but apparently
I'm okay no yes no maybe so damn it
how am I gonna get a level three okay so
I'm a little bit lost but I'll figure it
out in the time between this episode in
the next so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation move it is
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]